have you ever
cheated maybe in school you didn't study
for a test so you glanced over at your
neighbors answers hoping that he or she
was a bit more prepared than you were
did you ever get caught cheating pretty
embarrassing right copying someone
else's answers because you know you
don't have the right answers and then
being exposed as a
cheater complete utter total humiliation
now you know how Muhammad felt over and
over and over you could dedicate your
entire life to studying the various ways
Muhammad plagiarized other people's
stories but in this video we're going to
look at five examples of Muhammad
plagiarizing the New Testament
specifically the words of Jesus and Paul
the Quran admits repeatedly that the
people around Muhammad kept accusing him
of copying the stories of other groups
Surah 25: 4 to5 and the disbelievers say
this is not but a lie that he has
fabricated and another people have
helped him in it they have indeed
produced a wrongdoing and a calumny and
they say they are fables of those of old
which he has had written down and they
are recited to him morning and evening
Surah 6: 25 those who disbelieve say
this is is not but fables of those of
old sah 9: 61 and among them are those
who torment the prophet and say he is an
ear they called Muhammad an ear because
he would believe the stories of anyone
who came to visit him but don't take my
word for that we have the historical
background in Ian isak page 243 where
one of his critics declared Muhammad is
all ears if anyone tells him anything he
believes it quite frequently Muhammad
plagiarized myths and legends from late
apocryphal sources but sometimes he
copied the good stuff in Matthew 25
Jesus who referred to himself as the son
of man says when the son of man comes in
his glory and all the angels with him
then he will sit on his glorious Throne
before him will be gathered all the
nations and he will separate people one
from another as a Shepherd separates the
sheep from the goats and he will place
the sheep on his right but the goats on
the left then the king will say to those
on his right come you who are blessed by
my father inherit the Kingdom prepared
for you from the foundation of the world
for I was hungry and you gave me food I
was thirsty and you gave me drink I was
a stranger and you welcomed me I was
naked and you clo clothed me I was sick
and you visited me I was in prison and
you came to me then the righteous will
answer him saying Lord when did we see
you hungry and feed you or thirsty and
give you drink and when did we see you a
stranger and welcome you or naked and
clothe you and when did we see you sick
or in prison and visit you and the King
will answer them truly I say to you as
you did it to one of the least of these
my brothers you did it to to me then he
will say to those on his left depart
from me you cursed into the Eternal fire
prepared for the devil and his angels
for I was hungry and you gave me no food
I was thirsty and you gave me no drink I
was a stranger and you did not welcome
me naked and you did not clothe me sick
and in prison and you did not visit me
then they also will answer saying Lord
when did we see you hungry or thirsty or
a stranger or naked or sick or in prison
and did not minister to you then he will
answer them saying truly I say to you as
you did not do it to one of the least of
these you did not do it to me and these
will go away into Eternal punishment but
the righteous into eternal life so in
the New Testament version we have the
son of man speaking at the Judgment
telling people that when they didn't
feed the hungry they didn't feed him
when when they didn't give a drink to
the Thirsty they didn't give a drink to
him when they didn't visit the sick they
didn't visit him nearly six centuries
later Muhammad had a message for his
followers but this time it wasn't the
son of man speaking to people at the
Judgment it was Allah speaking to the
son of man aka the son of Adam at the
Judgment sah he Muslim
2569 Abu hura reported Allah's Messenger
as saying verily Allah the exalted and
glorious would say on the day of
Resurrection oh son of Adam I was sick
but you did not visit me he would say oh
my Lord how could I visit thee whereas
Thou Art the lord of the worlds
thereupon he would say didn't you know
that such and such servant of mine was
sick but you did not visit him and were
you not aware of this that if you had
visited him you would have found me by
him oh son of Adam I asked food from you
but you did not feed me he would say my
Lord how could I feed thee whereas Thou
Art the lord of the worlds he said
didn't you know that such and such
servant of mine asked food from you but
you did not feed him and were you not
aware that if you had fed him you would
have found him by my side the Lord would
again say oh son of Adam I asked drink
from you but you did not provide me he
would say my Lord how could I provide
thee whereas Thou Art the lord of the
worlds thereupon he would say such and
such a servant of mine asked you for a
drink but you did not provide him and
had you provided him drink you would
have found him near
me sound
familiar our Muslim friends love to ask
where did Jesus claim to be God and we
can give them a lot of examples of Jesus
making claims that only God can truly
make but we have one right here Muhammad
said that Allah will say these things at
the Judgment Jesus said he's the one who
will say these things at the
Judgment who does that make
Jesus and Jesus said it first next in 1
Corinthians
29-10 the Apostle Paul declares
but as it is written what no eye has
seen nor ear heard nor the heart of man
imagined what God has prepared for those
who love him these things God has
revealed to us through the spirit pay
attention to the order here no eye has
seen nor ear heard nor the heart of man
imagined I ear heart I ear heart nearly
six centuries after Paul wrote first
Corinthians Muhammad had a message for
his followers sahil bukari
7498 narrated Abu hura the prophet said
Allah said I have prepared for my
righteous slaves such excellent things
as no eye has ever seen nor an ear has
ever heard nor a human heart can ever
think of eye ear heart Allah even kept
them in the exact same order as the
Apostle Paul tell me what's more likely
my Muslim friends that Allah copied the
Apostle Paul or that Muhammad copied the
Apostle
Paul in Matthew 6 Jesus teaches his
followers how to pray he says and when
you pray do not Heap up empty phrases as
the Gentiles do for they think that they
will be heard for their many words
do not be like them for your father
knows what you need before you ask him
pray then like this Our Father in heaven
Hallowed Be Your Name Your Kingdom Come
your will be done on Earth as it is in
heaven give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our debts as we also have
forgiven our debt and lead us not into
temptation but Deliver Us from Evil and
in Sun Abu daud 3892 Muhammad teaches
his followers to pray the prayer is
quite different from normal Muslim
prayers but quite similar to what Jesus
taught narrated
abuad I heard the messenger of Allah say
if any of you is suffering from anything
or his brother is suffering he should
say our Lord is Allah who is in the
heaven holy is thy name thy command
Reigns Supreme in the Heaven and the
Earth as thy mercy in the heaven make
thy mercy in the earth forgive us our
sins and our errors Thou Art the Lord of
Good Men send down Mercy from thy mercy
and remedy and remedy from thy remedy on
this pain so that it is healed up this
Hadith is a little different from the
other hadiths we read in that it's
classified
Asif doesn't mean Muhammad didn't say it
daif just means there isn't ient
evidence that it's authentic so you
wouldn't want any Doctrine resting on it
but let me ask the Muslims who are
watching do you believe that Muhammad
was copying what's called The Lord's
Prayer here or do you believe that this
was fabricated by a later Muslim who
copied the Lord's Prayer and falsely
attributed it to muhammmad
sometimes it's difficult to know who the
plagiarist
is next next in John 20 Jesus appears to
his disciples after rising from the dead
but Thomas who is a bit of a skeptic
isn't there here's what happens now
Thomas one of the TW called the twin was
not with them when Jesus came so the
other disciples told him we have seen
the Lord but he said to them unless I
see in his hands the mark of the nails
and place my finger into the mark of the
nails and place my hand into his side I
will never believe 8 Days Later his
disciples were inside again and Thomas
was with them although the doors were
locked Jesus came and stood among them
and said peace be with you then he said
to Thomas put your finger here and see
my hands and put out your hand and place
it in my side do not disbelieve but
believe Thomas answered him my Lord and
my God
Jesus said to him have you believed
because you have seen me blessed are
those who have not seen and yet have
believed verse 29 is the relevant verse
Jesus says have you believed because you
have seen me blessed are those who have
not seen and yet have
believed mnid Ahmed
12,578 isn't available in a volume in
English yet as far as I know but you can
can find Muslims quoting it they love
what muhammmad says here anus IB Malik
reported the messenger of Allah peace
and blessings be upon him said blessed
are those who had faith in me and saw me
and blessed seven times are those who
had faith in me and never saw me almost
exactly what Jesus said to Thomas in
John's
gospel finally we read in Matthew 20 for
the Kingdom of Heaven is like a a master
of a house who went out early in the
morning to hire labors for his Vineyard
after agreeing with the laborers for a
daus a day he sent them into his
Vineyard and going out about the third
hour he saw others standing idle in the
marketplace and to them he said you go
into the vineyard too and whatever is
right I will give you so they went going
out again about the 6th hour and the 9th
hour he did the same and about the 11th
hour he went out and found others
standing and he said to them why do you
stand here idle all day they said to him
because no one has hired us he said to
them you go into the vineyard too and
when evening came the owner of the
vineyard said to his Foreman call the
laborers and pay them their wages
beginning with the last up to the first
and when those hired about the 11th Hour
came each of them received a Daenerys
now when those hired first came they
thought they would receive more but each
of them also received a Daenerys and on
receiving it they grumbled at the Master
of the House saying these last worked
only one hour and you have made them
equal to us who had borne the burden of
the day and the scorching heat but he
replied to one of them friend I am doing
you no wrong did you not agree with me
for a Daenerys take what belongs to you
and go I choose to give to this last
worker as I gave to you am I not allowed
to do what I choose with what belongs to
me or do you begrudge my
generosity so the last will be first and
the first last sahil bukari
7467 narrated Abdullah Bin Umar I heard
Allah's messenger while he was standing
on the pulpit saying the remaining
period of your stay on the earth in
comparison to the Nations before you is
like the period between the Asser prayer
and sunset the people of the Torah were
given the Torah and they acted upon it
till midday and then they were worn out
and were given for their labor one kirat
each then the people of the Gospel were
given the gospel and they acted upon it
till the time of the Asser prayer and
then they were warn out and were given
for their labor one Kat each then you
people were given the the Quran and you
acted upon it till sunset and so you
were given two kirats each double the
reward of the previous Nations then the
people of the Torah said Oh Our Lord
these people have done a little labor
much less than we but have taken a
greater reward Allah said have I
withheld anything from your reward they
said no then Allah said that is my favor
which I bestow on whom I
wish are you starting to understand why
people kept accusing Muhammad of copying
other people's teachings and stories
most of Muhammad's early followers came
from a pagan background they didn't know
what was in the Torah they didn't know
what was in the gospel they didn't know
what most other groups believed unless
those other groups popularized their
stories but a visitor would come to town
and tell Muhammad a story the next day
Muhammad would step outside and say I
have a
revelation some of the listeners would
respond as they respond in Surah 8 verse
31 of the Quran we have heard already
had we willed we could have said the
like of this this is not but fables of
those of
old and they would make fun of him but
his companions didn't know any better
they would say alhamdulillah such a
powerful Revelation it must come from
Allah not from the guy who told Muhammad
that story last
night his companions were ignorant and
they fell for it but you're not ignorant
because I just showed you five different
Revelations Muhammad clearly got from
Christians who were quoting Jesus and
Paul if you like many many more examples
of stories Muhammad copied from other
groups just pick up a copy of the Quran
and start reading if you love plagiarism
reading the Quran is like taking a ride
on the plagiarism coaster at plagiarism
land on plagiarists get in free day
[Music]